qu'a récemment déclaré elle a fire
justement à propos de mathieu de
l'ambiance il devrait retourner
présenter move comme mon chien il a une
grande gueule
son talent est inversement proportionnel
à son ego il est aussi beau qu'il est
bête où il faudrait bien de s'occuper de
sa propre carrière il ya du boulot
la tête j'adore je vais vous dire et
j'aime beaucoup elle a fire non moi je
trouve qu'il a énormément de talent ont
choisi et hier dans tpm dont on avait
parlé de l'émission un couple parfait ni
même par elsa fayer et franchement alors
là c'est gentil mais j'aime beaucoup
elle a fire mais l'agencé a buzzé un
mathieu était hyper gentil mais avait
prononcé une petite phrase lors du débat
en disant qu'elle anime et des
programmes qui selon vous était loin
d'être excellent et elsa fayer vous a
répondu
et c'est moi même qui veut répondre à
l'isaf ailleurs dans un instant non mais
regardez la jolie intelligente hier dont
et pmp on parler de l'émission du couple
parfait animé sur la chaîne tf6 par elsa
fayer l'occasion pour les chroniqueurs
de donner leur avis sur le programme
mais aussi sur son animatrice c'est ce
qu'a fait matthieu delormeau au sujet
des la fire qui me fait de la peine
c'est de voir qu'elle a d'ailleurs là
pour aller chercher un joker et c'est
une fille lui a animé une carrière c'est
d'abord dire non une petite phrase qui
se voulait à la base amicale mais qui a
sonné comme une leçon la réflexion de
trop pour l'animatrice qui sur twitter
n'a pas hésité à répondre à matthieu
delormeau il ferait bien de s'occuper de
sa propre carrière il ya du boulot
bref pas sûr que ces deux là ils bientôt
déjeuner ensemble
alors elle a dit donc que tu ferais
mieux de t'occuper de ta propre carrière
franchement j'aime beaucoup elle a
failli en plus je trouve que c'était
hyper gentil trek vous aviez dit et elsa
fayer ne sais pas je trouve que c'est
peut-être qu'ils roulent à mal rapporté
le truc et je trouve qu'elle a un peu
dur avec ans oui et si je peux me
permettre voilà elsa je trouve que
mathieu pour mathieu ça se passe très
très bien en termes de carrière il a une
hebdo qui cartonne sur ces 8 il est là
tous les soirs dans un dd le talk show
dont parle le plus et le talk show qui
fait le plus parler et le premier talk
show de france donc merci mathieu voilà
merci elsa et je pense vraiment que
mathieu voile a fait une carrière qui
ont des parcours seront maintenant tu as
une très belle carrière et je pense
qu'elle a voilà il a dit ça parce que tu
aimes bien oui je n'ai vraiment il a il
a dit ça ya pas de mal mais je pense
vraiment qu'il n'irait pas ni midi
couple parfait disais juste que tu
méritais mieux et que c'est vrai que tu
mérites mieux vaut la réponse pour moi
tes inepties njoh un genre de valérie
bénaïm bah oui voila je trouve voilà
franchement je trouve là et je trouve
que voit le benhaim à l'aurais pas fait
dit couple parfait assez gentille qui
l'habite et des antilles mais je veux ça
te dire que c'est pas vrai combat par
proposer quelques émissions de télé
rites et je crache pas dessus c'est
juste que j'ai 45 ans j'ai avancé du
permis de faire ça juste le fils est
jolie elle est intelligente qui règne
chez ruquier
et quand je vois qu'on lui propose carré
vip accroît fiancée la villa des coeurs
brisés et tout oui elle devrait parfois
dire non est allé voir la chaîne et dire
donnez moi des chaînes plus à mon niveau
après nous verrons d'abord mais bon moi
je pense qu'elle n'a pas regardé parce
qu'il ya on a commencé tout ça à 10 ans
du bien sûr m donc je pense qu'il a
juste l'article c'est planter
complètement les affaires quand on la
connaît
j'ai bien regardé après mdi je serai
lève très bien là si valérie peut pas
marcher ou qu'elles viennent de tourner
à ta vous l'a même dit de venir autour
de la table je pense qu'elle a lu
l'article et l'a fait ça aussi je pense
qu'à la vue est solution humainement
rapporte que la week-end il baisse la
tête qu'elle est déçue aussi qu'on ne
lui propose pas d'autre chose et des
fois quand c'est un travail c'est
difficile d'en trouver et peut-être
qu'elle se sent aussi à bien non c'est
difficile de dire maintenant
d'intonation plaie qu'est ce qu'ils
disent les prix nobel l'a donné c'est
difficile de refuser du travail s'il
vous plaît tango et cash là c'est tout à
fait normal qu'elle réponde toi tu
répondes la même manière
[Musique]
les trucs allait répondre parce que ça
caillait un tout qui commence à m'agacer
il ya une semaine plaza je l adore il
est drôle je vais regarder je n'étais
pas dans l'émission est la salève un
petit peu moins bien marché celle là du
coup un amour et je dis juste que sur
plaza il ya trop d'émissions immobilier
ça m'ennuie un peu et le lendemain je
vois sur yahoo matthieu delormeau écrasé
insultes browser mais c'est mal je veux
mais ça c'est le chou n'ont pas écrasé
un cigare est élogieux on l'a tous eu
des comptes mais bon on les adore les à
des frais ça suffit on va pas les
déplacer tous les jours à l'etec